elvis is rocking back i got him all lit
up he looks you can't see it doesn't
look good
it does it does look good it does look
good it looks it's but it's starting to
look like because
so troy got a an an i guess it's a it's
a
it's a statue type thing but it looks
like a bust
you're right but it looked like when i
first saw it i thought that the head
come
came off and you put cookies inside like
it looks like
it looks like a cookie jar but i could
see i say that sure
yeah and there's now he's lit behind it
and i've been watching the last couple
days experimenting with the colors
yeah and it now looks like it looks like
uh
what's it called when you okay the blue
looks a little different
i like that when it's yellow it looks
like it's a
what are those things called for dead
people that you build like a mausoleum
no no yeah i know what you're talking
about you know i'm just blanking on the
word oh
[ __ ] all the chords
yeah it looks like an elvis [ __ ]
shrine behind uh a shrine yeah
it looks kind of like a shrine or
[ __ ] uh to the king or a [ __ ] horse
yeah
to the king behind troy with the guitars
around him and everything i'm not gonna
say it looks bad
no it's pretty cool yeah you know it's
like
mike montone has his flashlight lit up
and on display uh
troy has elvis and the guitars around
him you know
but outside your point is that somebody
who
who buys a an elvis bust might not
he's got no business talking about this
[ __ ] you know how much was the overall
it was 300 i talked him down to two you
paid 300 for that elvis bus
200 i said 200. bro i thought you spent
like nine dollars on it it's a flea
market elf
used elvis bust that's maybe the dumbest
purchase i've ever heard in my life it's
not like it's elvis's actual thing
like nobody owned it like it's not like
it was from graceland
it's a state this shit's 50 years old
it's only going to go up i know it
thanks it's a stinky elvis bus
wait is that 50 years old probably yeah
it's probably
yeah it's probably probably early early
70s
that's pretty cool do you think troy has
dreams of taking it to antique roadshow
and getting a good valuation
talking about it's gonna go up in value
but
i have dreams of him doing that as well
and then it's [ __ ] falling onto the
concrete
like as soon as they say this is a rare
item it slips out of his nervous hands
i'll tell you why it's probably 50 years
old because it's probably spent the last
40s sitting at that flea market
waiting for a sucker that'll pay
hundreds of dollars for a
stinky elvis bust
yeah i don't i love it i saw it and i
was like i need that i need to go home
with that one
you were like in the 40 year old version
uh for 40 year old virgin jonah hill in
the ebay store
when he sees the glittery disco boots
and he's like these these are
spectacular i'd like to
i'm just trying to find this best yeah
yeah sam you don't think that you don't
think that that was a new item
that that had just gotten to the flea
market the day that troy
got there yeah no you think it was
sitting there for weeks possibly months
or years
it opened with the flea market it was
there was one of the one of the original
flea market items that were there
i love it i think it's great i saw it on
your instagram i was like that's a
perfect troy purchase i love it
but if you had asked me to guess
how much the elvis bust was i wouldn't
have guessed over 15
i thought it was one of those like
garage sale finds that you're like oh of
course i got to get this
yeah it was worth it to me i i
appreciate uh
finding something like this is this gem
and everybody you know
we'll talk about a flex i put that on
the gram everybody's sweating it you
know
you know what i gotta be honest uh
montone just sent us something
um it's a 1970
bust elvis in platter uh i don't know
why bust is with an e maybe that's how
it's spelled
uh 245 dollars
and mine's better than that that one
looks like [ __ ] i mean it looks like the
same thing
all yours is the same but a better
condition one it just looks better
shatter more in your life oh my god oh
that's actually bigger than i thought
too yeah that's bigger way bigger than i
thought it was okay i ran in front of
him
it's like it's almost lifetime would you
have laughed
if he tripped and you just saw that
thing it looked like the [ __ ] statue
of liberty at the end of the plan of the
apes
[Laughter]
that's actually way bigger than i
thought dude i thought that was like a
little
heavy probably 30 pounds i mean it looks
like it's out
the size of elvis it looks like it's
almost life-size that really is
and and i'll tell you the the reason i
think it's the exact same
bust except this one on
etsy that they're trying to charge 244
for
it look the paint is sloppier than the
one you have troy it looks like
the etsy one they might have tried to
touch it up
and done a bad job but yours has very
nice paint on it
looks very life like looks oh man it
looks like elvis look at that with the
sneer in his lip and everything
it looks really nice it's his head is
bigger than troy that's
massive so yeah yeah awesome purchase
awesome
and i'll be honest that actually is a
write-off because it's part of the
show's fabric
and now that it's right there on camera
yes
yeah and you get the backlight on it all
right